Hôm nay, tuổi đường thái, tuổi đường đầy kênh hoại sắp nhập bởi tay của Israel đã làm ra
tăng xức em hoại sào tự Mỹ và nhiều cuối xa trong khu vực.
Qua sinh tên cho sang về cô Hội Israel sức tiến cơ sửa lập nè ác chù quyền tệ mở tay,
có thể anh hưởng tới nỗ lực của tổng thống Trump, nhằm thuộc đầy hoa bình dưới
Israel và Hamas.
Chúng khi đó, các nước gạo lập coi đe bất đi hợp thức hoa, các khu định cơ bị xem là bất thật pháp.
Đồng thời tái khấn lịch lập trường ủng hộ thành lập nhé nước Palestine, giờ trên bình dưới năm 2019,
các tổ chú của tệ cảnh báo sẵn.
Điều Israel đã quyền kiểm soát thành chính và an ninh tại tuan bộ bởi tay không chỉ vì phạm lập pháp của tế,
mà còn có hủy tơ làm pháp vỡ cấu chút đối thoại mong mạnh hiện này.
Chúc khi đó chính khu Israel lập lộn săng, biệt sâm nhập là cần thiết,
để bà đam an ninh của sạch và phù hợp lập pháp trong nước.
Căn thẳng hoại sạch được dự báo sẽ còn kiểu sạch.
Khi mà các bên trước tìm được tình nói chung về sạch pháp hai nhận nước.